بارز في مسيره اردوغان السياسيه عكست صوره
المراه التركيه المحجبه التي اعانت الرفض
الاجتماعي حازت على اهتمام المتابعين
للشان التركي بتواجدها شبه الدائم الى
جوار زوجها يحدثكم عن السيده الاولى امينه
اردوغان
[موسيقى]
رفيقه درب الرئيس التركي كما تصف نفسها
والشاهد الاقرب على مسيرته السياسيه منذ
بدايته وحتى توليه مناصب قياديه
[موسيقى]
ولدت امينه جولبيران في الحادي والعشرين
من فبراير شباط بحي اسكودار في اسطنبول
عام
1955 لاسره ذات اصول عربيه تنحدر من ولايه
سرت جنوب شرقي البلاد تعلمت في كليه مدحت
باشا للفنون ثم انضمت الى جمعيه النساء
المثاليات التركيه حيث التقت اردوغان اول
مره عام
1977 وبعد عام واحد فقط عقد قرانهما
وانجبت له اربعه ابناء هم براق وبلال
واسراء وسميه
هذه السنه
لم ترضى السيده امينه البقاء مشاهده
لمسيره اردوغان السياسيه بل قررت منذ
البدايه ان تكون فاعلا مؤثرا ففي عام 84
تولى زوجها منصب رئاسه فرع حزب الرفاهيه
باسطنبول فتولت معه رياده الحركه النسائيه
التي دفعت الحسبه مستقبلا الى سده الحكم
ومع تاسيس حزب العداله والتنميه لاحقا
بدلت جهدا كبيرا في تعزيز جناح المراه في
الحركه السياسيه وسعت للتواصل المباشر مع
الشعب طالبه تقديم الدعم للرؤى التي
يتبناها زوجها وسعت لتنظيم حركه النساء
مساهمه بذلك في النجاحات التي حققها حزب
العداله والتنميه على مدى اكثر من عقدين
متواصلين عرف عنها التزامها بالبروتوكولات
الدبلوماسيه وجذبت الانظار بمرافقتها
زوجها وهي ترتدي الحجاب في تنقلاته
الداخليه والخارجيه مشهد لم مالوفا الى حد
كبير في تركيا واثار ردود افعال رافضه لان
تكون زوجه رئيس الوزراء محجبه لكن هل
انتهت تحدي هنا كلا بل امتد ليشمل ابنتيها
اذ اضطرت الى ارسالهما للخارج من اجل
اتمام دراستهما الجامعيه فقط كانت دخول
المحجبات الجامعات التركيه محظورا انذاك
في عام 2003 اقدمت السيده امينه بالتعاون
مع وزاره التربيه الى اطلاق حمله هيا الى
المدرسه ايتها الفتيات التي قبلت بحماس
واستحسان جميع شرائح الشعب وفي عام 2015
اطلقت حمله لمواجهه زواج القاصرات لكونه
انتهاكا لحقوق الانسان وبعد اربع سنوات
فقط اطلقت مشروعه صفر نفايات للتقليل من
المخلفات وبناء ثقافه المعيشيه جديده
شكرا
اظهرت امينه اردوغان تاييدها لعده قضايا
انسانيه ففي عام 2010 منحتني
تقديرا لجهودها الشخصيه في جمع تبرعات
لضحايا الفيضانات في باكستان وفي اغسطس اب
2012 التقطتها عدسات الكاميرات ودموعها
تنهمل تاثرا باوضاع اقليه روهينغا المسلمه
ومنذ ان انتهجت تركيا سياسه الباب المفتوح
امام اللاجئين السوريين
حريصت على اجراء زيارات متكرره لمخيماتهم
ودعت الى استنفار عام ووقفه اكثر اخلاقيه
ومعنويه فيما يخص اللاجئين ومع اعلان موعد
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
الرابع عشر من ايار مايو حرصت السيده
الاولى على البقاء الى جانب زوجها والظهور
معه في جميع جولاته الانتخابيه
برايك الى اي درجه يعتبر دور المراه فاعلا
ومؤثرا في حياه رجال السياسه في العالم